[Musique]
pour aider kédy à se sentir moins seul
elle va te reconnaître et te voir comme
son principal utilisateur ça va vous
permettre d'être jumelé toutes les deux
[Musique]
génial je sais c'est dingue non
ta mission est de protéger Kedi au mieux
de tout dommage physique et émotionnel 1
2 3 va te faire chinois il ne t'arrivera
rien de mal avec moi c'est trop beau
Mégane n'est pas humaine qui dit tu as
pas le droit de dire ça
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que tu fais là je ne dors pas
maintenant tu vas me dire
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que c'est que ça
c'est l'acte tu es censé fuir
il n'arrivera plus jamais rien de mal
avec moi
j'ai fait quelque chose qui te contrarie
Djama je sais que tu as l'impression
d'optimiser ta fonction logique mais tu
es sérieuse
[Musique]
il faut abandonner son lancement et moi
qui croyais qu'on était amis
j'ai un nouvel utilisateur principal moi
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui va pas avec Mégane
c'est quoi cette histoire
qu'est-ce que tu es au juste